yes
[Music]
that is
what's up
[Music]
foreign
if anything
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
what's up
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
the three Muslims today we are joined
with a very esteemed guest he's a PhD in
biblical Islamic hermeneutics and the
speaker of three different languages not
just any languages but some and maybe of
the most difficult languages to learn
and speak that is Hebrew Greek and uh
Arabic
how are you doing today
this has been a long time coming we saw
you on a blogging theology we've done a
lot of great work and great
presentations on there so I suggest
everyone check that out inshallah and
we've been trying to make this happen
for uh for a hot minute now so it's a
blessing to have you here
um as a young man who's uh discussed
with many many Christians and um you
know people who will always reference
the Bible
I have many many questions for you so I
hope you're ready inshallah for all that
we'll do our best inshallah
uh and everyone in the comments feel
free to send your questions forward but
just to begin I want to know a little
bit about your your background not so
much your educational background but
maybe more so your upbringing and why
you decide to get into the field that
you you studied
so
um I don't know I've just always sort of
been interested in
in uh discovering the truth
um keeping an open mind you know
um
I was born in Iran and many Iranians who
came to America uh are very secular
right not very religious I would say
um so
um most of my friends growing up I grew
up in the East Bay of California most of
them were were Christian they were they
were white they
um they took me to their churches uh
they tried to convert me I would say at
the time
um I didn't really subscribe to any one
religion uh just sort of interested in
in different sort of belief systems
so I attended uh multiple churches uh
even a Mormon Sunday school for a couple
of years actually uh and and they had
mashallah they had the macula they're
very moral people right
um but when I got older I looked into
their Theology and I said whoa what's
going on what's going on with this
theology
um so none of that sort of stuck with me
um none of it sort of resonated with me
now I did you know I was I've been
studying the New Testament I've been
reading the New Testament since I was in
elementary school or grammar school
whatever you guys call it up in up in
Canada
um and uh so I kind of fell in love with
with uh Islam before I knew anything
about the prophet salallahu right
um but the Theology of Christianity
right
um it just I just found it so strange I
found it odd
um
I didn't understand it
um I tried to understand it and I had it
explained to me
multiple times by uh my friends my peers
by adults my pastors
um
the Trinity to me just was something
that was
uh just uh something that I could not
penetrate at all you know and I thought
well
this this isn't working so when I was in
college
um when I started college at 17
um I was uh I took an intro to business
class and uh the the professor put us in
alphabetical order in the class and I
noticed that this this guy behind me he
had the same last name as I did
uh so I asked him are you Iranian and he
said no I'm Afghan he said okay and then
he said uh are you Muslim and I said
yeah I'm Muslim and I had you know sort
of
um been converted by I guess you could
say by Malcolm X
um when I was 15 years old uh so I
started to call myself Muslim I didn't
know how to practice or anything so I
had not met like practicing Muslims
until I got to college
I said he told me about the the MSA and
he took me there
um and uh so I went there and uh I
started to really
uh you know study Islamic theology
um I mean at the time at a very basic
level but to my surprise Muslims believe
in Jesus right and that's something I
needed to hold on to because like I said
I sort of fell in love with with Jesus
from from the from the Bible right but
but the theology didn't stick so and
then I discovered that yeah we can I can
believe in Jesus
um but I don't have to believe in the
Trinity I don't have to believe God
and I but I can still love him and so
um it came to this realization that
basically the uh the this teaching our
christology about Christ peace be upon
him right our belief about Jesus peace
be upon Him is given through the prophet
Muhammad so he is the sort of means of
our guidance
uh so then I started to appreciate the
prophet salallahu and of course I
started to learn about the prophet
studying the Sierra
um engaging in the Shema of the prophet
salallahu and immediately you know fell
in love with him uh and he became the
most beloved of human beings to me
um and and so that's that's sort of the
uh the story in a nutshell
wow subhanallah so when do you think you
you really made a a smooth transition to
you know a Muslim kind of I'm saying a
Muslim to wow I am Muslim
yeah I think it was um
I think it was uh one uh I first
attended
um like classes of of sacred knowledge
all right so what yeah when I was 15 I
saw this movie Malcolm X right I
actually remember the date the exact
date was November 18th 1992. wow I was
four days short of my 15th birthday
and so my dad for for no no apparent
reason I don't know why he just said
let's go watch this movie Malcolm X
and I thought to myself yeah I've heard
of Malcolm X but I don't know why he
wants to watch these movies so I said
okay Ellen let's go with him and so I
was sitting there and to be honest with
you I was bored for about the first two
hours uh and then
um you know he he goes to Hajj
and there was something about
I don't know something about the the way
that those scenes were filmed you know
Spike Lee was a director uh that just
resonated with me deeply uh and then I
was kind of just sitting there in the
movie theater
kind of just dumbstruck just kind of
staring at the screen and I actually sat
through all of the credits
you know and at the end of the credits
he actually they show the a picture an
image of the autobiography of Malcolm X
I
went to my local library over here uh
and I checked it out and I took it home
and I started to read it and it's very
thick and at the time I mean I'm 14
years old almost 50. so then I went to
the chapter on Hajj
after I read that chapter I remember I
closed the book and I said okay I'm
Muslim
I just made it up in my mind
that I'm going to be Muslim I didn't
know anything about the practice of
Islam that didn't come until about three
or two or three years later when I
actually attended
um I was about 18 years old so Sheikh
Hamza Yusuf who's the president of of
our College say tuna he was teaching a
class on Maliki fit
um um and so uh I went there and I
didn't know what Maliki was I don't know
what fifth is
but I I just I was just watching him and
I was just completely just just floored
by you know his demeanor his knowledge
you know I remember he started writing
in Arabic on the board and I said wow it
was mind-blowing he can he can write
Arabic uh
uh and so uh it's from that point on I
said okay I need to learn this religion
I need to start practicing this religion
so that was the sort of turning point
for me so these two men really Malcolm X
that she comes up really unique people
in me sort of embracing the religion
wholeheartedly
nothing happens by coincidence you know
it's it's times like this when you look
back and we all have these moments where
it's kind of similar to your father
taking into the movies you know and it's
not until way later that you put
together the pieces and realized that
everything happens for a reason I know
like a lot of non-muslims they call it
the butterfly effect we call it the
color of Allah but Allah plans in the
most perfect ways possible subhanallah
so and eventually there I think got a
point where you just you know really
really leveled up so would you say it
was at some point during studying you
know uh and achieving your PhD or after
you achieved it where you got to this
level where it's like you know wow you
know this is Dr aliyatai he's on
blogging theology he's super
knowledgeable he speaks three languages
that's a big one like speaking three
languages
is this a part of your PhD
well I mean
I would say I only really speak English
right I mean you can tell what language
do you dream in what language do you
cuss in that's really your main language
uh so yeah I have an academic
understanding of these other languages
I've always been interested in language
like I said you know like I grew up sort
of reading the Bible and but I wanted to
know like what the actual text says
I don't like translations what does a
text actual say in its original language
yeah uh so it was more um yeah if I
officially sort of learned these
languages
um in graduate school but uh I I studied
them independently to a certain extent
as much as I could uh before that time
you know kind of taught myself the Greek
alphabet and the Hebrew alphabet
um you know started to read Arabic a
little bit uh but it wasn't yeah my
formal studies in graduate school where
I started to engage in these languages
and and it's really important to do that
you know you know sometimes
um you know people character
characterize me as sort of being you
know anti-christian or anti-biblical and
things like that but I've invested so
many years of my life to studying the
Bible it's because I respect it as a
text and I really want to know you know
the history of this text
um you know there's a lot of Muslim
apologists who
will attack the Bible and you know sort
of be constructed but they haven't
really done a lot of studies in in the
Bible
um and so
um you know I encourage people that if
you're going to criticize a text to do
it academically and to do it with a with
a uh with a um obviously with a good
intention but in a way that sort of
reflects if sophistication and an actual
attitude of respect for the text
so yeah I've studied this text for for
many many you know years
um because I honestly want to know the
truth you know I want to know what's
going on with this book what's going on
with these gospels who's Paul you know
um you know what's who wrote the Old
Testament when was it you know sort of
canonized
um
what do these words actually mean in
Greek and Hebrew
uh so for me you know it's uh
you know in the Bible also is it's it's
easily the most influential text in the
history of Western Civilization
you know is Mark Van Doren uh said in
Liberal education he said if if if you
don't know uh the Bible if you don't
know who Abraham Moses and David are
that you've been miseducated
you know we and we're Muslims living in
the west we we need to know this text we
don't have to be experts we have to know
something
right
um
because the Quran does engage with the
Bible the Quran I would say in many
cases expects you to know the subtexts
of many of its ayat
right because the Quran is engaging with
Biblical tradition uh with tradition of
the late antique you know the sort of
backstory uh is taken for granted we
have to know what's going on with the
Quran
um
we have to know what's going on with the
Bible in order to understand some of the
the stories of the Quran uh we can get
into some of that later if you want but
it's it's you know it's I would say it's
important parcel of our tradition as
Muslims to engage a little bit with
Biblical history because you know before
the prophet
they were the Muslim um
right they were the people of wahi they
were the people that were given India
you know so um it behooves us to study
these texts and these traditions in
order to understand our own tradition
yeah I think I think that's very
beautifully said because a lot of the
time and you'll see this on apps that
are kind of all over the place like Tick
Tock you know people just two young
people jumping on alive together and
yelling at each other a Muslim will say
horrible things and Christians say
horrible things and none of them really
seem to take care
um I think academically is too gracious
of a word to use I don't think they care
about you know even the discussion on a
very basic human level so I think it's
important
um to ask this and then I think we can
get to the the specifics later I myself
and I think many others are wondering
what is the best way for a Muslim to
interact with the Christian in 2023 hmm
yeah that's a very good question
um
you know uh
we have a lot in common with with
Christianity and I would say Islam is by
its nature
you know conservative we have we have
conservative values we believe in family
values right we believe in human nature
we believe that human nature informs if
you want to call them gender roles you
know uh the word gender wasn't you know
actually used for human beings until the
20th century we had their two Sexes like
if they want to use that type of
language we believe in uh you know
objective truth with a capital t
you know
um we're closer to UC Berkeley
their school motto is uh feat Luke's let
there be light from the Bible right
that's from Genesis you have other
schools uh Luke's at Veritas Right light
and truth but these other schools they
don't they don't teach traditional
religion they don't they don't teach
truth with a capital T
right
um because that's seen as you know
archaic and Antiquated and offensive and
etc etc etc
um but Christians to hold on to their
tradition
right we have a lot in common with them
um and uh certainly in the face of the
current Zeitgeist which is totally
anti-religious and anti-tradition and
really anti-truth I mean you can make
your own truth right everyone has their
own truth and you hear this a lot I'm
going to live my truth well there's only
one truth right and that's and that's
what we believe and so the Quran you
know what does the Quran says
let the people of the Gospel you know
um judge by what Allah has revealed
therein this doesn't mean I mean some
Christians they quote this verse and
they say this verse means the Bible is
completely uh um accurate and and
imperfected no I mean the Quran and this
this is what we want we want Christians
to follow their tradition
right this is this is good for this is
good for the world that they follow
their traditions because there is truth
in their tradition
and they believe in objective truth and
they believe in objective morality
whereas you look at what's happening
right now in our society it's a total
jungle
right so certainly we have a lot in
common so I would say that you know when
we engage with Christians obviously we
have to do it with Adam you know and you
know for me you know
you know when I was an undergraduate we
had this we had this Thursday night
um Farmers Market where you know I went
to school in the Central Coast of
California and that's known as sort of
the California Bible Belt you know
California does have a Bible build uh so
we would go out to the street we make
all the and we'd debate all these
Christians and thank God I thank Allah
that none of those things are this is
pre-internet free YouTube none of that
stuff is on is on uh is online
you know
um because you know debating is very
difficult and you know I wonder like
some of these guys that go out and they
debate people in the street and they
post them on YouTube
you know when they turn 40 I think
they're going to regret
um most of what they
what they posted right why do you think
that is I think that's interesting why
do you think that is
it's you know debate right this is an
art form you really need to have
incredible Adam
you know it's you almost have to
completely move your ego
uh from that right because you have to
really have a you know obviously a very
sincere intention for the guidance of
the other person
excuse me the Quran
tells us how to how to debate right how
to engage with people
um
so when we engage with people uh debate
we have to do it with not only like like
you know basically like proofs
um
um you know scriptural proofs historical
proofs Etc theological proof but also
with good comportment with a good
attitude
uh with a sincere intention for the
guidance of the other person
and it's very hard to do that the ego
gets involved especially if you know
there's a camera there and you know
followers and
uh I think it's just almost impossible
unless someone is very very disciplined
right with years of training right
people forget the inward Sciences they
have to study these things to see
YouTube enough is very very important
so I tell you a true story what happened
to me is I was at one of these debates I
was you know 21 years old or something
and I used to go out there and you know
just completely annihilate these these
poor Christian guys
um you know and uh I look back at it and
actually it turns my face red just
thinking about what I used to say to
them but I used to go out there and do
that and um I remember
I remember you know the brother was
talking about like Allah you know he
does things and you know um
according to his plan that
you know we should take uh uh we should
we should heed so I was there and this
older Christian guy was there and he was
listening to me and he said to me
he just said you don't care about us you
don't care about our guidance
I said well what are you talking about
and he said you just want to come here
and embarrass us
and of course I said no you can't you
know you can't answer my questions and
that's a cop out and this and that
you know and then I went back to my dorm
room and I literally had like an
existential crisis
because I'm just sitting there and I
said he's right
this is all nuts
right uh I was honest with myself and so
I said look okay I'm gonna do this the
right way I'm going to actually
study the Bible I'm going to study its
history I'm going to study its languages
I'm going to renew my intention and
actually try to engage with the
Christians in a way that is according to
the ethos of the Prophet sallallahu
when he called people to Islam he did it
with uh with great concern for them
right and you know this is this is
something that is known in our in our
tradition at the prophet salallahu had
incredible concern for the guidance of
his people
yeah uh and the day of for example when
the angel came and said to him
um you know if give me the uh be okay
basically and you know we'll destroy the
city of thought and he said no I have
hope in their descendants and his only
concern that day was you know what is
this sort of what is Allah's opinion of
him right if this is happening to me and
you are uh not angry with me then I
don't mind let it happen all right his
only concern was Allah's opinion of him
not the opinion of the people
it's a you know it's it's a difficult
thing to do
you know so
um but yeah I mean we should talk about
things we have in common with with
Christians is we have a lot of things in
common especially nowadays but we also
have differences and those differences
matter
right so you know we're not going to say
that it doesn't matter it's you know two
sides of the same coin it isn't you know
you know whether you're reading uh
lazali or Aquinas it's just sort of
semantics no we're not saying that
either there are real differences
between these religions
uh but in phase of the current Zeitgeist
we can certainly come together with
Christians and voice our opinions as to
you know just sort of uh advocating a
modicum of of Sanity in the world that
there is truth there is falsehood there
is there is there are things that are
moral there is a man there is a woman
these things are I mean we knew these
things not too long ago but apparently
uh We've spiraled into a tactical chaos
yeah mellow protected from it um and I
really love the point you made um before
about sincerity I at one point I was
supposed to give a speech so I was
thinking about
um you know how the process really
transformed the sahaba because you can
argue yeah you know they're like Arceus
for example they help transform the
youth sometimes but
a lot of the time not to the the degree
the process the process he made like
people who hated each other love each
other come together as one and really
just literally conquer the earth
eventually get down you know some
generations that is tremendous and if we
as especially as Muslims don't study how
he did that then we are you know we're
we're falling behind greatly I'd say so
I was looking into what was it that he
had and I I just came to the conclusion
that he just actually cared about them
he really just cared about them he was
sincere and and you know he didn't just
teach them Islam he genuinely loved them
he genuinely wanted the best for them to
the point where he said oh Allah
strengthen Islam with you know one of
the two Omars
at the time was also an enemy of Islam
you know he made Dwight for both of them
and he said Ya Allah whichever whoever
you love more and then um who accepted
Islam shortly after that so he really
just cared about people so I think
that's a beautiful point that no matter
who we're speaking with maybe even you
know uh big names like islamophobic
names like David
and these people I think there has to be
at least some of us who genuinely you
know care for their guidance potentially
whether they accept it or not is up to
them but you know
right
this is a a uh a a concern the prophet
salallahu had for the whole of humanity
now he has a special concern for the
Believers but there is a concern for the
whole of humanity that he had right and
and you're right I mean if if we don't
want people to be guided if we want the
destruction of people
right I mean I I debated David wood in
200 six or seven something like that I I
make Dua for him you know I I honestly
want his guidance I don't want his
disruption I want him to be guided
um and uh that's I think that is the
prophetic ethos
guide all these people now you know
it's uh it's difficult but you know we
have to be we have to be very
discriminatory as to who we engage with
though I think that's important
because according to the Quran we're not
even supposed to platform like people
who Mock and deride our religion people
who Mock and insult the prophet
salallahu right
um Quran says Allah says that I will
take care of
I will suffice you
as against them right but that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't continue to pray
for people who do that because Allah
can change the hearts you know and as
you said
I mean he had the most evil intention in
the history of humanity
he had resolved upon the most evil
intention in the history of humanity
which is to go kill the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu
and Allah changed his heart
so um Allah is in charge of everything
you know but yeah I mean we have to have
we have to have we have to have this
type of prophetic concern for people
it's very very important uh to do that
do you think that a lot of people that
are either students of knowledge or
they're trying to take a scholarly route
and become more learned in Islamic
Sciences they lack understanding the
importance of adab and etiquette today
I think yeah I think that's the sort of
according to our Scholars this is the
the crisis of the modern world the lack
of Adam
right a lack of ADA or lack of
discipline discipline's a good word you
know the word disciple and discipline
are are linked right so the the uh the
person of Adam right is is the educated
person but also the The Virtuous person
you know and nowadays I would say
there's an epidemic
of of people who lackada
a lot of that has to do with social
media right I mean it's just um
uh
I mean I don't know if there's people
that are writing like dissertations or
Theses on what the the effects on of the
internet uh on on our sanity
uh but
um I'm sure it's quite profound right I
mean people waking up and
uh you know the first thing that comes
to their mind is not a
a Dua or to pray but you know checking
their phone to see who's commenting on
who's praising me who's who's
criticizing me
right
um
and then you know just sort of
giving into impulses
having a lack of discipline I mean I
I was on Facebook you know until 2017
and
um at some point I said to myself this
is there's some benefit to this but
um I think the harm out ways to benefit
um and it was difficult for me to sort
of just be civilized with people people
want to debate me people want to
I just said forget it I'm not gonna get
it and that's that's just me though I
mean there are people who could
obviously
I'm not saying you know get rid of
social media there's people that
obviously we can use it for
um a a good end and and with a good
intention uh but the most important
thing is the state of our heart and if
we feel like something is is corrupting
the state of our hearts that we should
get rid of that thing
right we should we should have the
ability to adapt the discipline to be
able to do that
right rather than sort of giving in I
mean this is the age of feeling right I
mean you have the age of Faith you know
the ancient reason now we have and now
it's the age of feeling
I feel this I want to do this I feel
like I'm this if it feels good do it
things like that so
um
you know it's uh like I said you know
this is a they're inward sciences that
we've neglected
um
yeah no uh and how to deal with with
arrogance with ostentation with vanity
you know we have we have a whole
tradition that deals with this how to
deal with these Sciences
[Music]
he had a sound heart
right a sound heart is the most
important
things bring to Allah
so I know a lot of the viewers are just
waiting for the crucifixion stuff and a
lot of the rational evidences but I do
have one last question on the tsunami
you have a question
no gopher bro okay so it's it's common
knowledge now and I'm sure with your
lived experience you know doing this for
a long time that there's a lot of debate
disasters and coming at it to prove a
point and defend an argument it's not
always the most conducive way to do
dollar to Christians so this being said
what advice would you have for being
aware of someone's emotional state and
emotional obstacles of leaving
Christianity and how would you tackle
that because I largely find that it's
rarely an A logical issue or a rational
issue but it's usually some type of
emotional attachment to Christianity and
they just have this block coming to
Islam
yeah um I mean it's a good question
there needs to be a you know support
system
um you know we expend all of this energy
to make converts and that's good but
when they convert they seem to be sort
of left to their own devices and many of
them Unfortunately they go back they
revert back to their old religion
because
they don't have that sort of support
system to continue to guide them
right
um so just to continue to you know to
keep contact with new converts to you
know welcome them to the community to
give them resources to answer their
questions
uh into a you know to um
to re reiterate these points I made
earlier that
you know if you leave Christianity
you know you're not leaving the love of
Jesus you know Muslims are required to
love Jesus uh he is a a a great prophet
in our tradition
um and so don't think like you're
forsaking Jesus or you're abandoning him
or you're turning your back on him right
uh he's a prophet in our tradition uh so
just to you know offer that type of
continued support and education for
Christians because it is you know anyone
who leaves any religion there's going to
be some trauma associated with that
especially with their family if they
have Christian parents it's very very
difficult to
to deal with with parents that are
constantly
um wanting to sort of you know debate
you or uh or and obviously they're doing
with good intentions because your mother
and father only want good for it
and then how do they negotiate that
pressure from their parents but also
having good adapt with their parents but
still having that sort of in Islam it's
it's a difficult thing but I think the
short answer the short answer is they
need to have some sort of continued
support system with the Muslims that
guided them to Islam and not sort of
just leave them out there just because
they convert it
um yeah there's a lot of comments on our
on our streams when we talk about
Christianity and we have a revert that
either takes the shahada or accepts
Islam and or they've already accepted
Islam and now they share their Journey
you see a lot of Christians commenting
how could you turn your back on Jesus
how could you turn your how could you
abandon Jesus how could you leave Jesus
and for me it's it's very easy to spot
that it's just out of ignorance I don't
think they're coming out the sideways I
just genuinely think they don't
understand Islam and how we view Islam
yeah I mean what what is what is a
Christian I mean if you ask a Christian
what is a Christian you might get an
answer you have to believe in the Bible
that Christian believes in the Bible
what well the Bible was in canonized
until the fourth Century I mean it was
athanasius his 39th Festival letter he
was the first one to articulate this 27
book Canon that was in 367. that's
fourth Century so there weren't
Christians before the Bible and said
okay okay to be a Christian uh you have
to believe
um that Jesus is God and he died for
your sins now according to historians
the earliest Christians did not believe
that
right this this is essentially online
Christianity I mean there were
Christians the nazarenes the ebionites
who were probably uh you know what the
nazarenes were the early church fathers
refer to the Nazarene to the second
century the ebunites probably a
derogatory a term uh but they didn't
believe that Jesus are those are those
not Christians I mean these are the
earliest so what is a Christian you know
a Christian is basically when it comes
down to it uh someone who believes that
Jesus is the Messiah wow that's what
that's what it means to be a Christian
according to this early as conception
right
um let's say Christian believes in the
Trinity that's again Trinity is fourth
Century the Trinity wasn't made
uh official until 381 of the Common Era
right I mean 324 or 325 yeah the Council
of nazia were you know Son of God
officially became God the son and then
381 you deal with the Holy Spirit now
you have the Trinity the first true
trinitarian theologians or the or the
cappadocian church fathers in in Turkey
uh and Augustine of Hippo these are
fourth Century 5th Century theologians
so that's what it comes up the the term
Christian in its original sense means
someone who believes that Jesus was the
Messiah and guess what Muslims believe
that Jesus is the Messiah right uh so
you know we are Christian in that sense
um and that the Quran purports to be
and I think you can support this uh
historically the Quran purports to be or
claims to be uh a um a restoration of
the original teachings of the historical
Jesus of Nazareth right and they're
they're Scholars who have mentioned this
you know you can you know Hans Kung in
so many words admitted this you know
Robert eisenmann uh uh James Tabor you
know they they've noticed these
parallels between Islamic I mean they
try to you know uh try to explain these
things naturalistically right so
historically right there might have been
epunites living in caves in Arabia the
prophet saws
their christology and things like that
so they have to have some sort of
historical or naturalistic explanation
as to how how Islam uh managed to do
that
um but but yeah I mean certainly
uh someone who becomes Muslim is
actually following the religion of Jesus
whereas Pauline Christianity which is
today trinitarian Christianity is not
the religion of Jesus it's religion
about Jesus
Christ
you know in the earliest gospel as you
know you know like he was asked by a
Jewish lawyer what is the greatest
commandment he quoted the Shema
that hero Israel the Lord Our God the
Lord is one he is
this is the exact word I mean their
exact cognates
and one here means one right
three one means one you know pan means
pen and table means table and man means
man and woman means woman it's a three
but he could have been he said one but
he could have meant three no he could
have said that he never said that
the word I had only occurs once in the
Quran
exactly yeah one and only and this this
is the plain meaning of the text right
Jesus did not teach trinitarian
Christianity
right even according to the New
Testament uh Paul did not even teaching
Christianity the authors of the New
Testament were not trinitarians they
were not unitarians either I don't think
Paul is a Unitarian I think he adopted
this kind of
um henotheistic
um uh of those of you that is prevalent
in the in the Greco-Roman world that he
was a highly hellenized Jew
um but I don't believe him when he says
that he was a Pharisee if he even said
that you know that's it's I mean um we
have to uh but anyway
um yeah trinitarian Christianity did not
become and Christianity did not become
officially trinitarian until way later
the fourth Century so this is the
religion of Jesus peace be upon me wow
wow that's very briefly said so a lot of
Christians are going to find that hard
to believe so I I kind of want to walk
through what maybe the majority of New
Testament Scholars claim or believe
about Jesus so it seems to be the case
that Jesus first first came as you know
what they call an apocalypticist that he
believed that there's life after death
in the end times you were coming and he
was a follower of the Mosaic law and he
actually came to make practicing the
Mosaic law easier for the people so he
came to the people told them worship one
God gave them basically reminded them of
the Mosaic law and maybe made some
things easier for them to practice in
terms of that law and legislation and
then sometime after Jesus you know died
or disappeared or left or was risen by
Allah
came a man predominantly I believe Paul
was the one who kind of orchestrated a
this kind of huge movement where he was
claiming Jesus Is God claimed to be God
died for our sins and so on and so forth
and then this christology
kind of became common I don't know what
point but at some point that Jesus was
God and that he died for your sins and
then throughout the next few hundred
years you have a lot of speculation on
how that worked you know is it this
hypostatic Union that he he has a god
nature and a man nature and they don't
contend with each other is it modalism
that Jesus had different modes is it
separationism that um you know you know
the it was separate somehow
um or was it eventually what came to be
trinitarianism that they're all co-equal
co-eternal apologize my camera just
dropped off but Dr Ali if you want to
jump in on that inshallah I think that'd
be great yeah so
I think I think the uh the problem is
that the um the first New Testament
author is Paul of Tarsus right
um and Paul was not a disciple of Jesus
uh nobody believes that that Paul uh
meant the historical Jesus of Nazareth
peace be upon him so he's the initial
author of the New Testament uh and
clearly from his letters and people
don't know this because they read the
Bible and they you know they read it in
its canonical order and you know after
the Old Testament you come to the Book
of Matthew uh then you have Mark and you
have Luke knee of John and you have the
book of Acts and then eventually you get
to the letters of Paul and you think
well this these are the orders of the
books uh chronologically but that's not
true
um everyone agrees that Paul's letters
were the first Christian writings that
eventually made it into the New
Testament right
um which is a bit strange because we
know from historical sources uh uh the
book of Acts um for what it's worth
historically as well as Josephus and
others that the early Christian Movement
uh after Jesus peace be upon him the
leader of the Christians was James and
it's amazing most Christians haven't
even heard of James who's James I mean
James you know the one of the Disciples
of Jesus that's mentioned uh no James
the brother of Jesus right yeah this is
what he's called James the just James
James the righteous he was the leader of
the uh of the early Christians of the of
the nazarenes in Jerusalem for 30 years
right uh where are his authentic
writings
uh he didn't write anything the oh the
only Christian that that was writing uh
you know these letters and Epistles Was
Paul of Tarsus
you know and there's there's 14
attributed to him only seven of them
according to almost the consensus of
historians only seven of them are
genuine genuinely Pauline written by
Paul the authentic from Paul in the New
Testament the other seven or six are
forgeries
um uh but but where are the letters of
James you know so it's like hearing one
side of a phone conversation right if
you're listening to someone talking on
the phone you can only hear what this
person is saying but you don't know what
the other person is saying so what is
what does James actually saying from
Paul's letters we know that he has
conflict with with other Christians
right
um read Galatians read First Corinthians
it's very very clear that he has enemies
uh that are Christians
um and at one point in Galatians you
know he he basically chastises you know
Peter James and John right so
um he has major conflict with Disciples
of Jesus
you know this calls in the question his
his vision on the road to Damascus
you know his his sort of
um experience apocalypses he at you know
who did he actually see on the road to
Damascus if if
um this vision is because of this
conflict that he's having with actual
Disciples of Jesus
then uh we are not out of line to
question
um Paul's sincerity or his uh belief
that what he saw was the actual sort of
Resurrection that resurrected uh Christ
uh because he is in major conflict
uh with actual Disciples of Jesus
um so that's a big problem and also the
four gospels as we said the written
after the Pauline Corpus so all four
gospels are highly influenced
by Pauline Christianity or Pilon
christology and Paul clearly believes
and I don't think
to me it's it's just very clear and and
people want to sort of you know
they want to obfuscate but it's very
clear that Paul believed that the second
coming of Jesus was going to be in his
own lifetime I mean just just read first
Thessalonians very very clear all of his
advice is predicated upon you know the
second coming of Jesus that's going to
be imminent right don't don't even get
bothered to get married right uh don't
even count on using your goods that
you've bought
um because uh we're going to be
transformed in the twinkling of an eye
and caught up in the clouds uh with the
Lord I mean he really believes that that
it's going to happen any day now uh and
that's it just it didn't happen you know
that's
um Paul was wrong about that
well unfortunately we have the four
gospels and in the earliest of the
canonical gospels the gospel of Mark uh
this idea of an imminent second coming
of Jesus is actually put into the mouth
of Jesus by the author of Mark we can
con we can conveniently call him more we
don't know who wrote the Gospel of Mark
but certainly a Pauline Christian who
did believe you know Mark is writing on
67 or 70 or something like that so right
you know at the end of the generation of
the Apostles the generation if it's 40
years you know
iscended around the uh around the uh
year 30. so you go ahead 40 years it's
right around 70. and the mark in Jesus
says there are some standing here that
shall not taste death and so until they
see the son of man coming in great power
the present generation will live to see
it all right and so the mark in Jesus
made a false prophecy that's not the
reality
right that is uh the mark in Jesus who
was highly influenced by Pauline
christology
but here's the thing I I want to see
I want I want I want to discover you
know a a uh an epistle written by James
you know and and the Epistle of James in
the New Testament everyone agrees that's
a fabrication James didn't write that
that's like a second century first the
second Peter Peter didn't write these
things you know Peter was an illiterate
fisherman from the Galilee I mean he
wrote These uh he wrote first and second
Peter that John the son of Zebedee write
the Gospel of John and historically this
doesn't make any sense if Christians
want to say yeah you know John the son
of Zebedee you know he waited until he
was about 90 years old and you know he
studied he studied a bunch of uh you
know Greek philosophy and he became a
master of the Greek language and then he
wrote his gospel finally and he said at
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the Word was God you
know he wrote that okay if they want to
believe that that's fine historically it
doesn't make any sense
none of the books of the New Testament
were written by Disciples of Jesus and
this is this is not something this is
not a polemical claim I'm making this is
standard you know New Testament
scholarship many confessional Christians
will admit to this right I'm not you
know insulting or attacking the Bible
here this this is just something that's
historically true uh among the vast
majority of critical Scholars of the New
Testament
uh so
um yeah I mean I would say that
I would say that Paul basically
um he married you know Judaism with this
idea of a dying and Rising
savior man God I don't believe that Paul
believed that Jesus was the god right
but but that Jesus was a god a Divine
Son of God right
um but not uh not uh identical to God
but equal and authority to God
wow and that's that's interesting and I
think that on the note of you know kind
of unanimous or majority opinion for the
scholars in New Testament scholarship I
feel that there's a huge disconnect
between the the New Testament Scholars
and the scholarship and like the
everyday average Christian because every
Christian that I speak to I say these
very basic claims that none of the
gospels uh let alone any of the other
books just the gospels were authored by
uh you know eyewitnesses or disciples
and they just cannot fathom it they just
they think that I'm just denying blatant
history and I'm like I'm quoting names
I'm saying you know C.S Lewis bar Ehrman
all these Scholars are saying
historically if they're agreeing that
one will never have the original and two
they were not written by eyewitnesses or
disciples and they can't fathom it so
what do you think is an effect an
efficient or effective way to get this
point across to the average Layman
yeah I mean people just have to be
honest with themselves and engage in you
know this is standard standard
historical studies of the New Testament
this is not some revisionist
you know like you know people today they
say like
like the Quran is an Aramaic it's not
Arabic and uh what is it the original is
in Jordan and I mean this is just
laughably Incorrect and this is this is
totally revisionist uh but what we're
saying about the New Testament is
completely mainstream historically I
learned these things in the Christian
Seminary I took a class
at a school called the Jesuit School of
Theology that's the name of the school
and our professor was not some you know
liberal California weirdo he was a
priest he was a Catholic priest okay and
in that class he taught us the
documentary hypothesis of Julius
wellhausen he taught us uh the two uh
Source theory of the New Testament uh
you know that Matthew and and Luke they
took for Mark but they also had another
source called Q uh and I said well
there's a q Source in the Q sources it's
probably pre-paul line
um you know and so it's not it's not
sort of um influenced by it by Pauline
christology and and you know I heard a
podcast recently with John Dominic
Crossing uh and he said that his you
know Scholars have tried to reconstruct
the Q Source document and he said in
Dennis McDonald as well they make this
point that there's nothing about the
crucifixion or so-called resurrection of
Jesus in the Q Source document in the Q
Source document is the earliest source
that the the gospel authors had had
access to so
you know I think it comes down to just
um you know like you said there's a
strong emotional attachment I know like
at some Christian seminaries they
actually have exit counseling
because they they have to sort of check
you know the faith of of Christian
seminarians leaving the same are you
like are you still a Christian after
going through the ringer I mean they
really
a really deep you know
um deconstruct
the the Bible in a very critical way but
it's still you know
you know it's it's a uh it's it's it's a
historical criticism of the text
you know
um uh so
um yeah I think it's just a
a lack of Education people need to you
know they need to step up their uh
but yeah like you said it's hard to do
that
yeah yeah 100 absolutely so we have a
few comments here I do want to get to
them because it's almost been an hour
already and I'm it's very clear that
we're going to need more than one part
so inshallah will definitely bring you
back very soon but to start the Super
Chat alsober says uh very happy to see
Dr ataya on the three Muslims podcast
learn so much about Judaism Christianity
thanks to him may Allah bless you all
um
from oh from mercy of France
I think it's Marcy Marseille sorry uh we
need Angel bro
[Laughter]
I'm Canadian too I'm supposed to know
French I know bro it's okay
so that's um
bless you we got a new revert uh I think
from kusheni to Islam tourist King may
Allah bless you we're gonna have him uh
this Wednesday on the podcast to make a
uh special appearance he said uh have
some watch Doctor uh Ali's videos he's
really good may Allah bless you
and I think this is something you're
just before but maybe if you have a few
remarks talking about Paul he was killed
for his belief he wasn't lying so if
someone's willing to die for their
belief then how could they be a liar
yeah I mean
do Christians believe that Muslims who
you know Muslims who die for their
belief
um they have to be right because they
die for their belief or like a Hindu who
gives his life
so it's just a non-secretary argument we
don't know what happened to Paul
the death of Paul is not mentioned in
the New Testament this is just based on
church history and tradition we don't
know what happened to the disciples wow
and this is not this is not like me
speaking as a Muslim you can ask a
secular historian what happened to the
disciples and they say we don't know
there are legends from the third and
fourth Century that that they were
martyred and decapitated and crucified
upside down and things like that
but uh we don't know what happened to
Paul I mean in the book of Acts chapter
21 or 22 something like that Paul is you
know he's sort of he's preaching in the
temple precincts and the Jews start
beating him
uh and then
um he basically appeals to Caesar
because he has Roman citizenship I don't
know how he has that how he has Roman
citizenship and then he's actually the
Roman legionnaires they come and they
they protect him and he gives a speech
and then they escort him back to Rome
and that's the last we hear of Paul in
the book of Acts what actually happened
and we don't know church history teaches
that he was you know decapitated and
he's buried somewhere in Rome but
you know that's that's those are later
Legends maybe that's what happened I
don't know but historically it doesn't
have a lot of weight we're talking
historically so but to answer the
question just because someone gives
their life for something it doesn't mean
that uh that what they believed was true
I mean certainly we know that right yeah
yeah even if they were they were
martyred or they died in kind of the
fashion of a martyr because we have many
Muslims as you mentioned I did that as
well so
and it seems to be the case that it's
not just you know this one point that is
very speculative it seems like almost
every fundamental point for Christianity
it's it's very speculative you know
there is actually even enough
speculation on the crucifixion of Jesus
definitely the resurrection you know
people love to quote Oh it's 500 people
who witnessed it but it's it's one
source that says 500 people so there's a
lot I think of just ignorance with
Christians in regards to their own faith
and in how certain these things are
historically and I think and I want your
opinion on this before I go to some
other comments do you think it's because
we don't have anything more solid than
the Bible like the Bible is maybe the
best historical Source we have for early
Christians in Christianity or is it
something else is it the faith
yeah I mean the only
I mean the the only sources we have uh
that mention Jesus from the first
century that are authentically written
in the first century or the gospels
right and I think most Scholars would
put the gospels in the first century
there were a few that would put you know
the Gospel of Luke in the second century
the book of Acts obviously is part two
of Luke in the second century the Gospel
of John many would put that in the early
second century even even sort of 110 120
something like that
but I think most would say that Mark and
Matthew are written in the first century
um there there are references there's a
reference a couple of references in
Josephus uh reference of uh to uh Jesus
of Nazareth one of them is probably a
total uh forgery uh we don't find it uh
in any uh
um uh it's not mentioned by any
Christian scholar until the 4th century
um eusebius of caesarea so he's probably
the one that fabricated it
um about about Jesus being sort of
killed in more than a man and things
like that very sort of Christian uh
undertones
um so for all intents and purposes
there's really nothing in Greek in in
Roman or Jewish sources that mention
Jesus so yeah we we're sort of stuck
with the New Testament sources
um but with the New Testament as I
mentioned you know if we engage in a
type of
um historical analysis of these Gospels
we can do a bit of um
uh a bit of uh separating the wheat and
the chaff as it were uh and uh Scholars
have dealt with these texts and so I I
would encourage people to to take a good
class on historical criticism when I say
criticism again I don't mean to
necessarily find fault with something
that's how we sort of use the word
criticism in our modern sort of you know
it's like the word apology no apology
for hundreds of years meant to defend
something and nowadays it means to say
I'm sorry right so criticism means to
really engage with something in an
academic sense right so I encourage
people to do that you should take a
class and you know and I encourage the
Muslims to do it with the Quran
you know uh I think the difference is
the more we engage critically with the
Quran historically the more our faith is
actually strengthened
um and this is this is seen with our you
know we noticed this with our narrative
right the Quran is is you know it's um
it was standardized in the seventh
century by the by the uh codex Committee
of Cigna uthman this was our standard
narrative for 14th centuries and of
course you have revisionists all
throughout that time challenging this no
it's an eighth Century document that
there was a committee of people who
wrote it and so on and so forth
but now this is becoming much more
mainstream among secular historians uh
but I don't think you can say that about
um the the New Testament
um gospels
um that when you actually study these
things and and
and uh at a deeper level at a historical
level
you'll notice that there are problems
right that are inconsistencies there are
contradictions
um you know if if Matthew believed that
the gospel of Mark was divinely inspired
why would he uh in a in in effect uh why
would he reject portions of Mark's
gospel there are things that Mark says
that Matthew doesn't like he didn't
include them why would he do that if he
believed that Mark was inspired by by
the Holy Spirit to write his gospel you
know the mark of Jesus
you know his final words on the cross
are this Cry of dereliction you know
right my God my God why hast Thou
forsaken me Matthew uh Matthew included
that but Luke didn't like that and Luke
has mark on his desk as it were right
but he didn't like he didn't he didn't
like the fact that the last words of
Jesus
was him accusing God of forsaking him of
abandoning him
right uh so
um this is a major problem
right if you want to say no no Luke you
know
Mark did not Luke did not have Market
well then you're you're putting yourself
in conflict with the vast majority of
critical scholars in the New Testament
all right
oh great answers
um five do you have any questions before
I jump to a few more comments
no man go for it all right so Orlando
actually let's start with the super chat
um he has Dr Ali about the Book of
Revelations who wrote it and where did
the author get his inspiration from to
write it uh love and peace brothers
The Book of Revelation it's not it's a
singular it's not plural The Book of
Revelation
um it's called The Apocalypse in the
Catholic uh virgin so who wrote it we
don't know who wrote it
um just like we don't know who actually
wrote the four gospels it's an anonymous
book
um it's attributed uh in Tradition uh to
uh to John of Patmos
now there are many Johns in the New
Testament is this a a John that is in
addition to the author of The Gospel of
John
many many Christians will say it's the
same John uh someone would say no it's a
different John so nobody knows who wrote
it okay
um
so it is the author of the of the Book
of Revelation writing about the end
times something that happened in the
future or is he writing about something
that's happening during his lifetime
that's also a question for historians to
ponder you know like what he says about
I think it's Revelation 13 18 you know
the the fairy on the Beast whose number
is 666.
right uh is he talking about the
Antichrist to come to the future or is
he talking about uh the emperor Nero uh
apparently the Emperor Nero's name in
Latin or Greek whatever it is the
numerical value of his name is
666. before he's talking about both for
this idea that he's sort of
referring to a historical figure at his
time but also there's there's sort of a
foreshadowing of a figure to come in the
future
um so the short answer is you know
historians don't know who wrote the Book
of Revelation I don't think the author
identifies himself if he does I'd have
to look back again at it
um
is it the same genre of the Gospel of
John that's a
that's a that's an open question yeah
and even even if he did identify himself
we would still have to bring in the
question if he's being truthful if it's
another fabrication correct yeah yeah
because like I said um you know there's
there are 13 letters of Paul that are
explicitly attributed
whoever wrote these letters identifies
himself as Paul but the vast majority of
historians would say only seven of them
are genuinely written by Paul the other
six are actually forgeries in Paul's
name so you know a Christian apologist
may say well you know doing something
like that in the ancient world wasn't
necessarily
um you know like you know immoral or
deceptive or something yeah but I would
disagree with that irman wrote a book on
on this topic called forged and he says
that by and large uh forgeries in the
ancient world uh were done with with ill
intention and with the intention of
deceiving their audiences
right uh so
I think it was a way to sort of save
Paul from
from a massive criticism that he was
probably getting like you know again the
first first uh Thessalonians it's very
clear that Paul believes the second
coming is going to be during his his
lifetime but in second uh Thessalonians
um you know uh now you have Paul saying
well there's a few things that have to
happen uh in the meantime uh you know so
it seems like whoever wrote second
Thessalonians was a was a Pauline you
know difficulty uh who tried to save his
master from massive criticism that he
was probably getting from other
Christians who are accusing Paul of
making a false prophecy wow wow and um I
I like I mentioned before I did an
interview with Dr Dennis McDonald with
inshallah we'll be edited and posted
hopefully soon we're just looking for a
uh
a podcast editor for the time being if
any of you know anyone let me know
inshallah and um he wrote a book
um and this isn't exactly the same right
as forgeries but something you discussed
and this is how I was introduced to it
literary Nemesis which is the idea that
you would take a story that already
exists with with you know a very you
know uh heroic figure or a great figure
from the past you would take that story
and manage to apply it to Jesus and make
Jesus not only the hero and main
character in that plot that you stole
but make him better than the original
person is somehow and they did this in
as Dennis McDonald described not a not a
a malicious way it wasn't in a malicious
manner it was just to get to a deeper
truth and really exaggerate this truth
about Jesus that he was so amazing that
he's like this person that I'm taking
this story from but even better and this
is done all over the uh the New
Testament and the gospels and I think
one case if this is I this may be or may
not be the same story you're just
quoting but one of the disciples or
students of Paul I think his name was
Luke
wrote that Paul saw this vision of Jesus
when he was on the road and there's a
lot of specific language use a lot of
specific plot points used and it's just
exactly the same as I think something
that was included in like a Greek play
or something like that hundreds of years
or years before the student of Paul
wrote it so I find it amazing that these
just blatant
um you know stealing of stories and and
maybe forgeries or Fabrications
um you know are out there and people are
not talking about it yeah I know you're
talking about something found in
euripides bakai right
um
uh pantheists right um
his encounter with Dionysus very similar
to Paul's encounter with these so-called
resurrected Jesus no this was this was
standard amongst the Greek novelists so
so Mark for example he said you know
he's a he's an elite Greek novelist and
this was the style of writing at the
time uh that they would borrow stories
um uh they would
um uh they would use what's known as a
flexible genre uh where they would
exaggerate certain things and and it's
another what he was doing and I think he
knew that his audience knew what he was
doing because this was an acceptable uh
practice uh I mean John's gospel he
moves the crucifixion date up one day
right and and the author of John's
gospel we can call him John it's not
like he didn't know that his readers
wouldn't figure this out of course they
would figure this out but that's not his
concern his concern is not necessarily
to do accurate history his concern is to
communicate his pristology so he wanted
to move the Christian the crucifixion
date up because that's that's fine to do
uh according to his genre of writing to
make a theological point that Jesus was
crucified on the day when the Lambs were
being slaughtered right so he was the
Lamb of God I mean Jesus called the Lamb
of God only in John's gospel in the
Baptist sees him in the beginning of
John's gospel he says Behold the Lamb of
God who takes the sin of who takes away
the sin of the world which is very
different than the Baptist the synoptic
tradition who was saying repent for the
kingdom of God is at hand right but you
know John doesn't really care about that
inconsistency because he wants his
christology
um to um
basically convince people as he says at
the end of his gospel these things have
been written for you to believe that
Jesus is the son of God the Jesus of
Messiah the Son of God
um right so this is this kind of
flexible genre and a lot of Christian
Scholars today are admitting this even
so Evangelical Scholars uh you know so
like for example the um in the gospel of
Matthew we're told that when Jesus was
resurrected these Jewish saints were
also resurrected they came out of their
graves
right some have called this sort of a
zombie apocalypse and whatever and they
walked around the streets of Jerusalem
right
um you know they're Christian Scholars
many Christian Scholars today will say
well that's you know
that's an example of you know sort of
special effects
this didn't really happen it's not
historical at the offer of Matthew uh is
trying to make a theological point right
according to his genre of writing and
that's true that's how the ancient Greek
novelists wrote their their their books
and novels uh but the problem is modern
readers of these things uh they're not
familiar with this genre so they believe
these things to be completely historical
uh and that's just not you know it's not
accurate according to you know we try to
read our own sort of way of doing things
today back into the ancient world and it
just doesn't work yeah and it's actually
it seems to very be very interesting
because
um
for example when Jesus allegedly says in
one of the gospels that just like I
think Jonah was in the belly of the
whale for three three nights um three
days three nights the son of man will
also be in the belly of the earth and
then so on and so forth and it's like
Christians will read this and be like
see he made a prophecy
and what seems to be the case is that no
someone stole the story from the Old
Testament about Jonah and then put it
onto Jesus in a form of literary Nemesis
to exaggerate this point that he is not
only familiar with the work and the
prophets but that he is divine in a way
or that he will be killed and
resurrected and all this stuff so it's
it's it's amazing you know what faith
does to a person because there is a very
rational explanation that is you know
congruent with all the different
examples that we discussed and that are
out there that Scholars have uh written
about and examined in depth but they'd
rather at this point believe that it's
all
truthful and that Jesus is God and all
of this stuff so I think it's it's very
interesting but I would love to dig
deeper inshallah and I think probably on
future episodes
um I do have a few more comments if uh
if we have time for that yeah go ahead
all right Bismillah so Jonathan thank
you for the Super Chat he says could the
Christ claimant uh that pulse on his
vision be the Christ claiming that Jesus
peace be upon Him warned against that
would misguide his ummah
um
did Paul actually have this Vision or
not
um who knows you know something did
happen to Paul I mean I have a
my opinion of Paul is you know I I
expressed it so I did a podcast with
with Paul Williams on on blogging
theology I encourage people to watch
that on the crucifixion before I get
into sort of my my stance on on Paul but
I'm just raising a question I mean if if
Paul claims to have seen uh Islam uh in
a vision but this vision is putting him
into conflict with disciples and that
conflict is very very clear we can see
it in Paul's own letters the genuine
Corpus the book of Galatians the First
Corinthians false enemies are you know
men of men from James men sent from
James you know well who's James James is
the successor of asab
uh he's the leader of the nazarenes for
30 years why is Paul in conflict with
these people
what does that say about the nature of
his vision with the so-called
resurrected Jesus right so that's all
I'm doing I'm calling these things into
question like is this was that really
Jesus is Paul really telling the truth
here maybe it was someone else that that
Paul saw
um so alone Adam
um
like I said unfortunately we don't have
anything authentic
from Peter or James right uh the Epistle
of James at first and second Peter these
are not written by James and Peter by
almost consensus of New Testament
historians
so yeah all right next question
I believe there is a Biblical prophecy
by Jacob that warned about someone that
fits a description of Paul of Tarsus
something like a Benjamin is a ravenous
wolf or something like that yeah there's
uh Genesis 49. yeah I explained that one
time
um also on a podcast
one of the early church fathers actually
I forget who it is I have to look back
at it but he actually identifies uh
Paul is being this ravenous wolf but
then he says well he you know he
converted and he became
he became uh you know a devoted follower
uh so they so even some early Christian
fathers they see that parallel
uh between between Paul and and really
Saul right so like Saul
because Paul's name is Saul right
Paul's actual name is which means the
one who's responsible interestingly
enough
all right so so Saul is sort of a uh the
type and then Paul of Tarsus is the
entity type so Justice Saul
um this is how they they explain it just
as King Saul persecuted David
right uh Paul of Tarsus will persecute
Jesus who's supposed to be the davidic
Messiah so even Christian authors they
saw that that parallel
um as well so yeah some some of the some
of the early Christian fathers they
identified Paul as being the ravenous
wolf
that was um that was prophesied by Jacob
on his deathbed but he became good at
the end because he accepted
gospel I see well it's very interesting
he's found a lot and uh last one I have
saved here is can you ask Dr Ali atai if
he read Benjamin Summer's work on the
bodies of God and if Genesis 18 was
heavily redacted
Benjamin summer no I haven't read that
okay and any comment on Genesis 18 if it
was heavily redacted
well I mean
the uh the the Torah as we have it right
um
there I don't know of a single
critical historian or critical scholar
who believes that that what we have
today as as Genesis Exodus Leviticus
Numbers Deuteronomy that this was
written by Moses on Sinai 14 you know
1400 years BCE
um I don't know anyone who believes that
even amongst most uh Jews I mean it's
only really the Orthodox who cling to
this position the dominant opinion is
that
um the Torah as we have it the
pentateuch as we have at these five
books
uh were really sort of stitched together
by a redactor around 500 BCE so they're
really four independent accounts
um of of uh of for for basically four
independent accounts of the ancient
industry-like history
and Scholars refer to this as the J
Source the e-source the D source and the
P Source this is called the documentary
hypothesis
it's still pretty much the standard I
would say at most you know Christian
seminaries this is not this is not
something that Muslims came up with to
slander the Bible this is something you
learn in Christian seminar okay the
documentary hypothesis of Julius
wildhausen
um and so uh the Book of Genesis is
really
uh
um a an amalgamation of these four uh
sources and one of the sources that J
Source written around 1000 BCE uh is
very anthropomorphic right the way that
it describes God
very human terms whereas uh and so some
some chapters of of Genesis reflect that
type of theology but there are other
chapters in Genesis that reflect the E
the E Source the E author who was more
Transcendent in his descriptions of God
so God is more Transcendent
um
uh so but I haven't heard of this this
man's work
all right and I think the last one for
the day is the Super Chat for Mark
oh sorry I said Mike Mark shout out to
Dr Ali and favorite uh my favorite
scholar AKA beast mode thank you for all
the knowledge you have put up on here uh
and your videos on the significance of
Islam I love you all mark
thank you Mark
um God bless and I think inshallah will
be good to wrap it up I do have one
final question for myself
um I feel like it might be a bit of a
silly question because every person is
is different in what works for one
person might not work for another but
would you say there is a best argument
for lack a better term or a best way to
explain to Christians the enlight of the
Quran why their theology is incorrect
and why Islam is correct
yeah I would I would appeal to
theological consistency right so so the
major reason why
uh the Jews rejected
Jesus is not because they rejected the
historical Jesus it's because they're
rejected the New Testament Jesus
right so the tunnel mode if you read the
talmud you know what what the Talman
says about Jesus is in reaction to the
New Testament Jesus that's not the real
Jesus right because a Jew could never
accept the New Testament Jesus because
it's a breach of tohib right and uh the
New Testament Jesus or the Christian
Jesus the sort of Jesus of Christian
faith taught his own deity
this is impossible to believe uh as a
Jew it's it's shirik it's idolatry right
uh a Jew cannot possibly believe that
um so
I mean how does how does one reconcile
you know the New Testament Jesus or I
should say that the Jesus of Christian
faith
with clear passages in the Old Testament
God is not a man that he should lie in
the me and that's sort of a strange
translation but the meat that's numbers
23 19. but the real meaning of that is
any man who claims to be God is a liar
wow right a man who claims to be God is
lying right so the Jews have that very
clear text right this is like more cam
it's you know it's very very clear you
know uh Hosea 11 9
UM
indeed I am God and not a man
right so
you have they have these verses so then
why would God suddenly become a man and
expect people to believe him and not
just any people Jews to believe him and
um uh you know in John chapter 8 the
Johanna and Jesus again this is not the
historical Jesus this is the this is the
Jesus of the Gospel of John and this
only happens in John the johannan Jesus
uh he tells the Jews that are arguing
with him that you are children of Satan
right we're Children Of Satan because
they don't believe uh Jesus's claims
that you know he's God according to the
standard sort of trinitarian reading of
these passages how could they believe
he's God they would commit blasphemy by
doing that and Christians admit that
that Jesus was crucified for blasphemy
he committed blasphemy so why would the
New Testament Jesus ever uh expect
anyone to believe in him if he's going
around
committing blasphemy
all right it doesn't make any sense you
can't blame the Jews for disbelieving in
him why would they believe someone who's
going around uh making Blasphemous
claims
uh so it's it's totally incoherent so
what Islam does right what Islamic
christology does is that it restores
right this
this to heed to the world the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the
greatest monotheist in the history of
humanity
right and so this is just a fact and and
monotheism is the the claim the fame of
the Jews they believe that they were you
know that that they were chosen by God
to spread the light of the one God
monotheism uh to the world so you know
Jewish writers in the in the medieval
period they were very very
um
um uh uh hesitant uh to uh to to ascribe
any type of kid or any type of um
deceitfulness on the prophet salallahu
because they recognize that he brought
monotheism like no one else
right so you'll find opinions of him
like for example Rabbi Nathaniel
al-fayumi in his book is called uh
or something
or something like that in Hebrew The
Garden of the intellects he says that he
believes that the prophet Muhammad is a
nevi emit which means a true Prophet but
he was only sent to the [__] he's only
sent to the uh to the Gentiles so like
the 99.9 of of humanity right and there
were many Jews even in Medina that
believed he was a true Prophet we read
it
that Jews would come and sit in the
prophet's presence and sneeze on purpose
because they wanted a prophet to say
to them and the Hadith says that the
prophet would say Allah
may Allah guide you and and
um so the Jews were very loath very
hesitant to ascribe any type of kids to
the prophet salallahu but the New
Testament Jesus you know it's it's
obvious for them this can't be a prophet
because a prophet would never ever claim
to be God a prophet would never claim to
die for anyone's sins this is in total
breach
of Mosaic tradition of of the Torah of
of you know hundreds and hundreds of
years thousands of years of Jewish
tradition
why would a rabbi at at a Passover seder
you know pass a cup of wine around and
say drink this this is my beloved would
a rabbi do that I mean this is this is
something that uh is uh is repugnant
um revolting
drinking someone's blood right uh
clearly this is not historical this has
not come from the historical Jesus of
Nazareth so I think that's a very strong
argument to make yeah Islam is really
and I mentioned this earlier is really a
restoration of the true teachings the
firstology of Jesus that brings back
this uh
this this rigid monotheism this tohede
right that you can continue to love
Jesus and honor him and follow him uh
but do not worship him because Jesus
himself did not did not worship uh
himself as it were do not claim to be
God but he worshiped the one and only
true God who was Allah and of course
Allah people get hung up on these terms
uh you know Allah is the god of Abraham
maybe we can do another podcast on this
topic Muslims say they believe in Allah
I mean Jesus spoke Syriac he didn't
speak Aramaic I mean sorry he didn't
speak English
um he didn't speak probably didn't speak
Greek maybe he did a little bit but in
his own language Syria or Aramaic uh the
word for God is Allah right that's how
we would have said God
um so uh and in all Semitic languages
you know the Atif lamb is found for the
for the word God in almost every
semantic language but that's a different
topic uh but I would think I would I
would point out that theological
consistency is a very strong argument
yeah I think that's beautiful and I
think it's amazing because it uses kind
of Judaism and their their theology as a
common denominator in a way it's like
we're not just claiming these things
about Jesus we're we're using the common
denom denominator which is the Old
Testament which is what Jews already
believed to show that listen if you if
you want to claim that Jesus was this
Jewish preacher and he came to the the
Jews and then you know died for the
sense of humanity okay no problem but
you still have to deal with all of these
what you pointed out inconsistencies and
I think that's amazing because I think
the way you articulated it was was
beautiful and I think that it's more
than enough for most people but if
someone wanted to take it further I saw
a few comments things like you know
hanging on a cross someone who hung on a
cross and Old Testament is a cursed
person sacrificing your own children
this is not something that's fathomable
from the Old Testament
um you know on top of the things you
mentioned so now despite the question I
think this is really good for the next
thing that we do if these things didn't
come from Jesus where do they come from
and I I if people want to get ahead on
that question watch
um the presentations that Dr atahi did
on blogging theology with Paul Williams
because he discusses this in depth with
different philosophies that were
injected into
um the christology of Jesus and and what
people believed about him so with that
being said so much uh everyone who came
and attended contributed
for joining us today it has been a
tremendous honor and I want to give you
in five the last words inshallah before
we end the Stream
I can't wait for part two men inshallah
with Donald this time because brother
Angel used to be you know he was a
Catholic he was a Christian and then he
reverted to Islam he's the third Muslim
in case you're wondering
yeah thank you for having me I love
bless you guys
viewers uh keep us in your prayers
inshallah
and with that being said everyone who
attended
will see you on the next one